I started
um my life as an engineer actually when
I was 13.
um building uh different things in
electronics I was fascinated by it
building you know different gadgets and
actually trying to sell them welcome to
20 minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is very special on deep
technology in a very very cool startup
please meet raviv melamed prior to
founding via rovivo's vice president of
the Intel Architectural Group and
general manager of Intel's worldwide
Mobile Wireless group
he joined Intel in 2004 as part of
Intel's acquisition of envara a fabulous
Semiconductor Company based in Israel
where he served as vice president of r d
prior to this he held several roles in
the Israel Defense Force in the field of
large-scale radar and communication
projects raviv holds a BSC and an MSC in
electrical engineering from Ben-Gurion
University Israel
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me how are you
good all good thank you thank you well
thank you very much for joining me it's
it's 10 p.m in nestsion where you're
calling from and I very much appreciate
your time and I even more than that
appreciate the the amazing work that
that you're doing with fire and 4D radar
Imaging and you can only imagine or
start to imagine the different
implications this can have on on our
world and our day-to-day and the ripple
effect of this in the industry but your
journey started long before that it
started joining joining Intel for an
acquisition where you were VPR indeed
your previous startup tell me a little
bit about yourself review how do you
sort of look at your own path and
entrepreneur or what time who are you
where am I it's a it's a
short question and a long answer but I
still need to find out so what can can
tell you that yet but um I started my
life as an engineer actually when I was
13.
um building uh different things in
electronics I was fascinated by it
building you know different gadgets and
actually trying to sell them uh
different kits back then it was uh you
know you could actually build things
with your ads it wasn't like chips and
things like that so that's kind of
started the whole thing and then in the
Army
um I was doing more complex systems
um then went to a startup and then uh
startup that was acquired by Intel and
then developed myself in Intel to become
VP and GM of the wireless group there
and then another startup called by our
and and just I think a month ago you you
announced that via achieved unicorn
status with over 100 million dollars in
fresh funding looking at 40 weight or
Imaging but but looking back for a
second we we had a short conversation uh
just recently about your work within
Intel it was really interesting to hear
how you came in to an underperforming
product or or vertical within Intel and
and managed to to through leadership
turn things around tell me a little bit
about what happened there and what what
you learn from that experience going
into via
yeah so I think in Intel I've learned a
lot
especially about how big organization
work
and what happens to an organization
you know at the later stage of it of its
life and let's call it
um how you kind of form a way of
thinking and how bureaucracy and not
really understanding the values
um creates you know a huge
um gorilla that can't really move fast
uh and basically missing things
sometimes right so obviously Intel is a
great company they do great things
um but a lot of it is based on the
inertia and trying to go into new
markets that requires different sets of
capabilities I would say and you know
the ability to give freedom to people uh
to go and operate but not just try it
but really take it all the way uh
through and not just throwing money on
it just really
um taking a real risk right so I think
that's something that you've learned in
your years as a as a corporate
um what my teammate and I did is
basically doing everything differently
uh compared to what was done before
um you know not really you know not
doing things on little fast moving
outside the retail to tsmc for example
or changing cost structures things like
that so there are a lot of things that
I've done over there but I really
thankful for anything to allow me to do
that obviously it was beneficial for me
to do but uh yeah that's kind of what I
learned there
and uh and then you I think you're being
very very humble with uh with the
different things that you've done over
there but but we'll leave that to
another conversation because I want to
focus on on fire take me back 11 years
ago you're after six years of being at
Intel you're advice you're leaving as
vice president you're about to embark on
a New Journey at the Deep Tech space 4D
Raider imagery what is what is the
problem that you're observing in the
world and and and where are you at with
this problem
yeah so so I think you know once I
decided to leave until
um I started to think about what's
what's the next thing that I want to do
um and I started to look at the market
and uh for me there were like three
routes one continuing with communication
which I did for many many years and I
really didn't find it interesting the
second one back then Homeland Security
was uh was a big thing
um I did that for part of it in the Army
so again wasn't interesting
um and the market that was interesting
for me was was the medical Market
because that was something that they
didn't do before and I thought that I'll
be able to do good things
um you know my knowledge Etc
uh and it was really kind of intriguing
to to go to that path so
we started like thinking about that
right and um I wanted to
see if I can do something else something
new
um one of the things I learned over time
is that uh that's not my enemy other
people said that it's going to want to
really create innovation in certain
markets the interesting thing is that
you can bring Technologies from a
different Market
to that market that suddenly good things
happen that's uh kind of what happened
over here
so one of the things that that was
asking myself
is why can't I use very quick kind of
frequencies to look into the human body
um and that was based on something that
they did in the past in the army that
took into Worlds with the radio waves
um and
um I started to kind of check if that
can be done what people did in the past
which is very important
um and I found out that they all got to
the same kind of uh
issue which was the cost of systems and
because radio waves were extremely
expensive to uh to do
and I think like every new thing it's
kind of uh everything kind of Falls the
same time to the right basis the
technology is there you know the idea is
there
and at that time my mobile
radar basically it just kind of really
started I mean people started to write
more articles so that was one thing mimo
Radars are multiple channels uh that you
need in order to get better resolution
um so my more radar was just at the
beginning of it and then silicon was
just starting to become very cheap for
RF so what I did in Intel for example
was mimo basically for wireless right
so when I looked at all those articles
and look at what people did in the past
I said hey you know if you use silicon
if you you come with silicon Concepts to
this problem
and then you can actually create Imaging
yeah and that was the moment I I was
like okay we have something here now
let's see what we can do with it which
Market is the right Market Etc and
breast cancer Imaging was the right
Market
uh for that to start with by the way
that we've just set the just to set the
the picture here you're sitting and
you're looking at this technology
emerging you're looking at the market
you understand that there's a time a
timing you understand that there's
knowledge that you have a team of great
people that you conform to this when
you're Imagining the world with your
with this technology with the new
devices what opportunities does it allow
for the world in general with better
Imaging and and better use of these
radio waves well what what can we do
potentially why is this interesting
yeah so so when we started and started
with uh you know with breast cancer
Imaging but we we quickly understood
that the same sensor can be used to
multiple markets that's what we do today
there's a whole philosophy why we're
doing it this way but we're not gonna
talk about it right now so when you look
at basically 4D Imaging call it 4D
because the fourth dimension is you know
movement speed
um but
um the moment you have a sensor that can
see through things
with high resolution
that can see in every environmental
condition
and it's very low cost then there's
multiple applications right it's
basically kind of having a Superman
Vision at low cost right that's that's
kind of it once you have super
motivation you get the magic but you can
do it right whatever you do with Optical
there's multiple applications that you
can use it for looking inside walls look
inside human body tracking people
tracking uh objects Etc so that opens up
a whole new set of applications uh in
the new modalities so that was the idea
that's how we started uh and that's the
first slide we showed to our investors
like using One sensor to multiple
markets
so so when you start with breast cancer
and what happens
so we started with breast cancer and
actually we started in parallel with the
two or three applications
um and we pitched four applications
fifth uh because we knew that each one
of them will take time and it's not that
easy picked medical
uh so when the student we need to run in
parallel which was very unusual at that
time today people are more kind of
bolted to it but back then people
explained to us that we need to focus
and all of that stuff which is true to
many other things but not specifically
to sensors
um and we started paralleling here one
Imaging
um testing
breast cancer Imaging and also a Imaging
in the in mass production of food okay
to detect from family that things like
interesting so I think we're done on
four different applications that we're
running in parallel and since then we
added several more applications like
Automotive Elderly Care etc etc now in
the beginning of this conversation you
mentioned that one of the things that
you took with you from sort of corporate
world was this idea of autonomy and and
really supporting vertical new verticals
or new domains within an organization
even and it's beyond just the money the
actual support and seeing it through end
to end is that is that sort of what
we're seeing here with you mentioned
that we're doing things simultaneously
and how do you as a CEO what do you
actively do to make that a reality
within your organization
yeah so so first of all it starts with
the structure
of the organization
so if you look at typical organizations
uh you have CTO organizations but you
what you find out over time is that the
city or organization you know dealing
with things like you know 10 years from
now 15 years from now and then you got
the bu's they leave the day-to-day they
need to deliver they need to solve the
problems today not
in 10 years and there's always a gap
between these ones and nothing that is
the CEO comes but not nothing but a lot
of the things that CTO do
when they come to The Bu The View is
like no no you're like totally not
related to our architecture you're not
related to the way we do things you're
not related to the market which is the
biggest problem usually uh Etc so what
we've created is an organization that is
self-funded
that can bring
a Innovation but that Innovation is
Market driven Innovation it's not
something that you know this we're not
research we're we're trying to solve the
next problems right and this is like
think about it as a filter if BD comes
with the market since that's the market
then come and talk to the customers and
we're doing proof of Concepts
in that organization so they're kind of
cleaning up the stuff that doesn't work
and leaving the ones that that work and
there is a customer in the market okay
and once that happens then we know we're
kind of vetting this then we know moving
it into the r d stage
um and then developing that new market
right so it's always Market driven
decisions
um and it's moving very very fast and we
fail fast okay and that's super
important because those pocs allow us to
you know do something doesn't work throw
it away you know we don't invest too
much time and effort in it it's not a
big deal until you find the right you
know thing that you need to really focus
because you have a tool for the market
to do the technology just like a startup
and you uh make it bigger and that's
kind of the the mindset by the way this
is exactly how Automotive started in VR
exactly how Elderly Care started to
player
um through that process
and generally are those verticals
entering bottom up top down who's coming
with who's sort of the champion of these
new verticals that are coming into VR
and and emerging because I'm guessing
that for every success there must have
been a few failures so you've tested a
lot
yeah I mean there's there's several
failures but uh the way it's done it's
uh done in uh it can be bottom-up or top
down it doesn't really matter at the end
of the day so this morning you guys sent
me one of our employees and we have a
new idea for the for by Arcade we can we
talk I said sure 30 minutes let's hear
his idea and
the first step of this idea is to go and
check check it out in the market right
so the BD guys will go and check it see
if there's something about it if there
is a customer is paying for a POC that
will go to the next step and if the
customer will pay for a project that's
probably gonna go to the end of the of
the road so so that's how we do it so it
doesn't matter who brings that here at
the end of the day it's a good idea it
will survive
I love it tell me a little bit about you
know who what what are different
interesting use cases for Via in the
real world right for for non non-deep
tax that don't necessarily understand
the technology here what what how is vir
positioned to change the way that we as
humans interact with the world around us
we mentioned you know breast cancer
Automotive elderly care but but what
arguably how is how are things changing
so just let's take Elderly Care as an
example is that okay of course I that's
I I love that yeah
so Elderly Care is a simple example
where today there's so many old people
in their homes
and you have no question right so
there's a very interesting psychological
element here which uh it's interesting
to talk about like for example you have
parents probably how old are they
right and if anything that your parents
we live forever right of course they
will that's how your money exactly and
your parents are will always be healthy
and all of that stuff and actually your
brain refused refused to understand the
fact that they're actually getting older
getting weaker Etc so that's one fact
the second part is they always look at
you as their as their son and they don't
want you to know what's going on with
them right
so actually the certain age 75 78 80
they're starting to fall but you don't
know about it because they're not going
to tell you and you don't even start to
think that they're falling okay
and then comes the Big Four
okay the big four is a folder they
cannot hide it
okay and then that thing suddenly
switches right then you start to really
really work be worried about them and
they're like no no it's okay and you
need to find some kind of balance where
you know that they are okay but you
still keep their dignity you still keep
their you know their respects to them
and all of that now you're not gonna put
cameras in your parents bathroom or
bathroom right but you will put a sensor
that keeps their privacy but monitor
them in a way that if there is a fall
you will know about it right you already
or they know about each other right but
someone knows
so that's the first step the second step
is even more interesting
so the Second Step talks about
preventive medicine and preventive
medicine means that you track a person
over time and compare data now there's
no single sensor today that can do that
in their home so when you think about it
talk about all people they're in a home
all the time so if you had a sensor that
keeps privacy for one here
that's me right but I still get the data
and I can analyze and alert
then a super important two examples I
give you one an elderly care facility
that we are tracking
um a person we found out that is sitting
on the sofa more and more time right and
the the
the medical team was alerted they
checked the guy and they found out that
he has heart issues
wow so basically that's classical
preventive place right another case was
with the woman that lost her husband
and they found out that the device
basically alerted them that that lady is
staying in bed longer and longer
basically she was kind of getting into
depression again send the medical team
she was getting into depression and
obviously they took care of her so when
you started to look at these issues
there's tons of them right for example
there's a clear correlation of
deterioration of your health but we kind
of in correlation with how many times
you go to to the toilet at night
so you don't know anything about your
dad but when you suddenly see that
suddenly he's going to the toilet more
and more at night that's a clear
indication there is something there so
he better get checked now right so there
is a very interesting bonus he wouldn't
even know that he wouldn't even track it
he wouldn't write it be aware of it
right and that's gonna change people's
lives dramatically right so love how we
start the conversation
talking about wireless communication to
breast cancer to a little bit about you
know the the technological piece of it
but then we're going all the way back to
human the human computer interaction and
it's not just you know breast cancer and
um Imaging but we're actually talking
about behavioral Imaging and being able
to to sense things that you know if we
are just able to to observe them in in a
sort of an unobserved world today they
can have some
direct implications that you know it
would ask me you know how it's predicts
what are the different behaviors that a
person may have that indicate this some
specific issue hey I think that's a
that's fascinating I love you thank you
so much for for spending this time with
me and this it's it's it's inspiring
what you're doing with vir I think that
the structure of allowing for ideas to
to be to to rise and to innovate all the
way to the end of the cycle where they
are full full-blown verticals within via
is awesome congratulations again on the
wonderful news and thank you very very
much
thank you and keep doing the great job
you're doing thank you thank you